And OUTFRONT now, Putin's
former speechwriter.
Abbas Gallyamov.
And Abbas,
thank you so much for your time.
We're hearing
about these heavy losses
for the Russian army You know Putin well.
You have been watching him closely.
What do you see right now?
Well, I see that
he is in a kind of a loss.
Judging by his actions,
you know,
like physically, who
he seems to be in good shape, much better
than he was in in spring and say,
April and May.
But judging by his actions
is making mistakes here.
He's acting erratically.
You know,
a lot of things which seem to be illogic
like he's appointing
one person, promoting one person.
Then in a couple of months,
he is demoting him.
He's giving too much power to precautions
and taking power from precaution
against the same.
Was Medvedev
the same with the prime minister?
So it's a kind of like if it looks like,
you know, as if he is at a loss
He understands that he has to act,
but he doesn't know what to me.
So his hands are moving by themselves
and he's just
lifting balances and counterbalances
and creating new balances.
And you better balance
with the things he was doing.
For many years he's accustomed to doing.
But now this is a different situation.
He needs a
different kind of action,
but he's unable to deliver that.
Now, in this context,
here of watching Putin,
I know you're focused on the next Russian
presidential election
and you believe that Putin needs
to announce his candidacy
in the coming months.
So if he's going to run,
he needs to announce that
in the coming months.
But you think he may cancel
the elections? What would that mean?
Well, judging
by his actions, when he is escalating
constantly without necessity,
he might really cancel the elections.
Uh, understanding that he will
without victory over Ukraine,
he will face a reality difficulties
with getting
the majority of votes of Russians,
you know,
without proving that he's strong Russian.
The Russians would need him
if he is not strong.
So he might really declare
the martial law and cancel the elections.
You know, people will be facing
more and more difficulties
The Russian economy is deteriorating.
The war.
The war is is lost.
But there are more and more dead
bodies coming
to Russia.
Russians will be
coming across more and more difficulties
in their daily lives,
and they'll be
trying to find the explanation
why this is happening to us.
And in this situation,
they're looking around in politics
into the political process,
and they'll be answering themselves.
Well,
this is because our country
is governed by a no parent
and no dictator.
And and at this moment, I think
a military force
or an elite or broadly
speaking, will become possible.
So in one year,
when the political situation changes
and there is a really hated,
unpopular president
at the head of the country,
and the war is real unpopular,
and they need to shed blood
for this Well, at this moment,
it all becomes a real possibility.
And just to be clear,
you're saying
this is a possible military coup
Well, I can say
military, but it's also possible to say
they will definitely have some
civilian allies to broaden this speaking.
It would be like
military elite or something in between.
All right, Abbas, thank you very much.
I appreciate your time.
Thank you very much.
And now I want to go OUTFRONT
to the former U.S.
ambassador to Russia, John Sullivan.
And, Ambassador,
it's good to see you again.
You hear a boss
talking about a change
that he's seen in Putin's behavior
since the beginning of the war.
Concurring with you
that he
thinks he looks physically well right
now, but referring to him as erratic
and it looks as if he is at a loss
in terms of what to do.
What do you see right now
and have you seen such a shift?
Well, thanks, Aaron.
It's good to be with you again.
Well, I'd
say I'd attribute it
to the stress of being one year
into a failed massive war that he started
He's flailing for ways to try to address
the obvious
shortcomings of his special
military operation
and he's operating under a lot of stress.
I think that accounted
for the change we saw
in his physical appearance last year.
He is in a very, very difficult spot.
And I think that's reflected in
his actions and his decisions.
And he doesn't have many go up.
No.
And, you know, in this
actually context, it's interesting
because you were the last person.
You spent a lot of time with him.
You know what you're talking about here,
your new replacement, the new U.S.
ambassador to Russia, actually
arrived in Moscow today. Right.
It was just today.
And Ambassador,
there were a group of protesters
there to greet her
and they were chanting,
war is a business for the US.
And, of course,
I guess
just to state the obvious
to everyone watching,
Russia does not have, you know, protests
except for when it does
as it
except for when
it's officially sanctioned.
And what do you make of this today?
Well, anyone
who was
protesting outside
the Russian foreign ministry
without the authorization
of the Russian government
would not only been
taken away immediately by the police,
but prosecuted and sent to prison.
This protest is obviously organized
by the Russian government.
They organized protests
outside our embassy
when I was ambassador.
Usually they were
for a short period of time.
We suspected that the people were paid
for their time. Maybe an hour.
They bring video cameras
that videotape
people with signs, chanting slogans,
and then they'd go home.
I'm confident
this is what happened to my
successor, Ambassador Tracy.
So to
win is a very,
very accomplished diplomat.
I mean, she's
used to dealing
with this type of situation.
But I must say, in three years
as ambassador,
I never had that happen to me.
I had crowds outside the MFA, media
cameras, video cameras, but
I never had protesters with signs
when I was going into the MFA.
And I think this is just a sign
of how
badly fractured our relationship
now is with Russia.
Well, today, the former U.K.
prime minister
Boris Johnson, talked
about a conversation he had with Putin.
And this was literally
just ahead of the invasion.
And when you talk about fractured
relationships, here's what Boris
Johnson said.
Putin said to him, listen to this.
You know, he he
sort of he threatened me
at one point and said, you know,
Boris, I don't want to hurt you, but
with a missile,
it would only take a minute
or something like that.
You know,
you know, Johnny
Ambassador, the Kremlin
spokesperson, Dmitry Peskov, said today
in response to that, what Mr.
Johnson said is not true.
More precisely, it is a lie.
What do you make of this?
Oh, I'm confident that
the former prime minister is speaking
the truth.
I saw it myself
when I would engage
with senior Russian leaders.
The conversation would go from zero
to 60 miles an hour
from a discussion about arcane aspects of
the Minsk agreements on trying to settle
the Ukraine problem
to a nuclear standoff
between the United States and Russia.
And I'd be taken aback
when my Russian interlocutor
would start talking about nuclear war.
My reaction to
that was if I had raised on my own
nuclear war I might.
The president
I worked for,
President Biden would,
if we called me, fired me,
and probably set me to have my head
examined.
What a negotiate tactic by the Russians.
It's one they've used all the time.
And I'm confident that
the President Putin
would say something like that.
Ambassador Sullivan, thank you very much.
Thank you very.